uh okay remember that if you'd like to
get on your nickname in the waiting
Lobby on Discord needs to be name and
location of where you're calling from it
doesn't even have to be real but it has
to be name and location otherwise you
are not going to be eligible to
participate today let's go to Carl from
Bremerton Carl welcome what's on your
mind today
uh how's it going David so
pretty much what I wanted to say was
um should I feel like I shouldn't be but
should I be celebrating the like win of
Tim Ryan against JD Vance in the line of
the year and it's getting a lot of
traction and whatnot even though I find
him much less liberal than I like but I
understand it's because he's in Ohio
yeah and he has to kind of walk that
weird line where he's got to get the
indecisor Trump voters but also let me
address what was the line of the year I
watched the debate what was the line of
the Year oh it was the the we need a ash
kicker not an ass kisser like everyone
saying yes
it was a good line like I I remember
being like wow like I was watching it
when you watch it and I reacted the same
way I I like Tim Ryan as a person he's
been on the show and I've had a couple
conversations with him off air like
before we we did an interview
um I to be honest I don't know Tim
Ryan's real politics and what I mean by
that is
at one point he seemed quite a bit more
Progressive to me than the way he's
running right now I understand the
Dynamics of Ohio may impact how he's
running he's been critical on issues
related to the border of Kamala Harris
and Biden and all these other things
um I think that as a practical matter JD
Vance is such a dangerous disaster that
like you just got to vote for Tim Ryan
if you live in Ohio it's obviously the
right decision but without a doubt the
way he's running now it's well to my
right that's for damn sure
um yeah and that's pretty much how I
felt was like Hey this I'm glad that
this is like because this seems like I
feel like if I was an indecisive like
voter that was like maybe thinking of
voting for Trump if I saw that yeah and
actually looked into it they'd be like
wow he is like awful I should definitely
vote for that guy but for me I'm from
Washington right so like I'm pretty
liberal anyway so when I see that and
then I hear him talking about how he
agreed with Trump I'm like yeah I don't
think
yo I don't think that's something I
would be like happy about no like then
I'm like you know he is in Ohio so I get
it yeah that's why I'm struggling with
what to do
uh overwhelmingly the better option and
also if he was a presidential candidate
I'd say you sound almost like a
Republican
yeah 100 yeah all right Carl thank you
for the call appreciate it thank you man
I appreciate it all right that's a big
race so I hope all of our Ohio voters
will indeed be a voting in that one it
is extremely extremely important uh
let's go next to Lucian from England
Lucian welcome to the show what's on
your mind
yes I can
ah there we go
um thanks for picking um first of all
how much are you keeping up with the
economic and political situation in the
UK what's a general take on it only a
little bit I if I understand correctly
it seems there are significant economic
concerns in the UK Liz truss initially
planned a tax cut for the rich which
correct me if I'm wrong she is since
abandoned because in the context of
what's going on it seemed like a
disastrously bad idea
yes that's right yeah and then I saw an
economic prediction that the UK could
have some serious hurt in front of it as
well uh no I don't know that I have any
particular opinion I mean I think the um
I I when I read the headlines about
specifically what's predicted in the UK
economically I wonder whether it's
really just going to be part of a bigger
economic shift in the U.S and Western
Europe like I'm not fully understanding
why this would be isolated to the UK
that's what I was going to ask as to
what extent some of the same issues
present in the USA as well
absolutely I mean our economies are so
tied together and dependent among upon
many of the same industry Industries
many of the same trade relationships
obviously our stock markets don't move
in lockstep necessarily but it seems
strange to see some sky's falling
predictions for the UK and then some
predictions in the U.S that after
December 2023 should actually look
pretty good it seems hard to imagine
that there would be such a stark
difference
we'll see what happens I think the the
interest rate question is probably the
most pressing right now
um it's pretty dire here I'd say in
terms of interest rates I'd say me and
my partner just bought a house two or
three months ago we managed to complete
that if we were
to have done it now instead we would be
paying 50 more per month on our mortgage
basically what are mortgage rates in the
UK
um when we got it was about two and a
half percent I believe now it's gone up
to six percent oh so similarly similar
to here yeah
yeah that's a big difference a good
thing you bought when you did I guess
very very lucky just another really
really question you said you've got some
Heritage from Eastern Europe right
oh yeah yeah I mean almost exclusively
have you have you actually been there no
I've not
if you if you'd be interested I'd be
quite curious to know what you think
about the culture and everything I'm
from there initially yeah I mean so one
of the things is my family being all
Jews from Eastern Europe
they you know spoke a different language
and sort of were relatively uh
concentrated in certain communities due
to some unfortunate realities at the
time
um and so you know I think that by by
and large the culture in which my
ancestors lived
primarily have sort of eroded in Eastern
Europe in you know Ukraine and Russia
and Belarus so I don't even know that I
could really I could go and see what the
culture is like now I don't think I
would have the experience of seeing what
was the culture that my ancestors lived
in because it's mostly gone
right I understand that that's really
really unfortunate yeah all right thank
you very much the call thank you
thank you all right let's take a very
quick break if you're holding don't hang
up because we're going right back to the
phones in a moment